We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a caller who says I should stop catering
to stupid people.
Take a listen.
Jay, David, I've noticed that a lot of the
time now you preface their talking points
with, well, just so you know, I'm going to
say something.
George W. Bush said it was reasonable right
off the kabuto said that was reasonable.
But just remember, that doesn't mean I lied.
Neil CAVUTO, remember, George W. Bush is a
war criminal.
Who cares if people can't separate a person
overall?
They're like what a person is overall from
then making a point that's fair or reasonable
from time to time.
If everything is guilt by association with
these people, who cares what they think?
Don't even preface this by saying it's just
stupid.
These people are students.
What do you guys think?
So what the caller is referring to is, for
example, recently George W. Bush put out a
totally bland, uncontroversial call for unity
around Corona virus.
And, you know, Donald Trump flipped out, attacked
him.
And I said, guys, you know, when when George
W. Bush sounds reasonable, given how terrible
of a president he was, you know, that things
have gotten really wacky.
And people started tweeting me, David, you're
normalizing your rehabilitating the reputation
of war criminal George W. Bush.
And I clarified a bunch of times that that's
not what I'm doing.
My views on George W. Bush haven't changed.
He just despite being so bad, he made sense
this one time.
Should I just stop the disclaimers?
I want to hear from you.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Barbers are cutting people's hair on the Michigan
Capitol lawn to protest the corona virus shutdowns.
We will talk about yet another company touted
by Trump getting a very, very fancy billion
dollar border wall construction contract.
Probably won't surprise some of you.
And Michael Cohen, Trump's former personal
attorney, is going to be released from prison.
All of those stories and.
More on the bonus show.
And remember, Monday, Memorial Day, one day
membership special, huge membership discount.
You want to take advantage on Monday?
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman got.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dicom.